hello look about the gay spots
continuing coverage of e3 2015 we're
here on the live show floor oh my
goodness
Jamie Jackson for freestyle games just
turned up I mean Machado is just avenged
sevenfold turns up as well you know like
I didn't no idea you were coming what a
pleasant surprise
yeah well such as the a B here yeah such
as the madness of of e3 and of course
Ben's here which is with your fancy new
ass plastic controller situation now you
were no stranger to making new
controllers obviously you guys based in
lemon inspired did DJ Hero one and two
and what was the like tackling the
guitar ah it was interesting man I mean
you know when we started to think about
it we were like you know it's gonna be
five years by the time we come back yeah
when we come back from a guitar would
have been gone and we were thinking look
we got to come back with something new
like if we just bring the same gameplay
everyone that's an expert player or
whatever is gonna get straight at it
everyone the only ever hit medium isn't
going straight hit medium look we want
to give you a new challenge so we
started to think about how could we do
it and we tried loads of different
configurations with the buttons and
things like that but what we figured and
some people say to me what is it about
you guys in three buttons with the DJ
here but you know the six buttons and
but we were like you know what so many
people only use three fingers when they
the game as soon as they have to use the
pinky and I was one of them freaked out
yeah we couldn't do it may as well chop
it off it's useless to me right and I
almost think those people are just
massive pieces of shits they can't even
use like all their fingers we were like
right we need to make something that
it's gonna kind of play into people's
play patterns you know where they got
where people are just using their three
fingers but how can we add depth to it
and that's really where the idea came
from it's kind of bringing that second
row buttons in above the top you know we
only bring it in on a slightly more
difficult level and it allows us to kind
of add difficulty but people don't get
out of their comfort zone by here having
to use their pinky so that was kind of
one of the first drivers and then really
it was like we started to go you know
what makes people feel like a rock star
and it was always the guitar yeah
everyone's like the emotion of putting
it on and we said you know what is that
and everyone kind of does this like a
guitar like can you do this it's like
the universal sign of it and this bit
we've got pretty right
yeah then we start to look what people
do this with their fingers they were
kind of going up and down the strings
kind of thing so that helped us kind of
drove us down that route to kind of make
this hand do something a little bit
different
excellent and map did you play these
games at all during the whole like
progression of the series I did yeah I
played them and I enjoyed you know the
more technical stuff when Dream Theater
had some songs got more progressive in
metal I enjoyed that because it was it
was you know quick fingers and people
that can really play the game it was
really impressive to me yeah it's a
completely different thing than when you
go and play your songs does it ever feel
anyway approximating what you're
actually doing with your guitar I like
it are there ever a moment sir my god
that's kind of there well you know
sinister would be the one to ask but I
since I do play guitar there I mean it's
close it's not close especially with the
way that the six buttons is set up
there's more of a chord progression
right you can do chords you would do
chords down there you can do multiple
buttons instead of going all over the
place because that would be like playing
a solo at all time yeah yeah this is
more like playing a real guitar so it
gets even closer with with this
controller
speaking of so does all the hammer on
sale work still good all that in I mean
if you see anything come up there with a
little glow around the base of it that's
that's what that is so for those who are
watching now the the white ones are the
ones on the bottom you guys sort of
telegraphed that by having them pointing
down as well yeah we thought we would
try and make it as easy as possible so
those pointing down and white that's
bottom row pointing up black top row and
then where you see their half and half
square so you might just saw that that's
both buttons gone one of the other
things that's happened with you guys
sort of reinventing this guitar is that
I guess when the Guitar Hero franchise
continued you guys kept in the guiding
instruments and whatnot the guitar
stayed the same for the most part there
was some mechanical differences and so
when a new guitar hero came out I was
like oh yeah I know how to use this you
know I'm a fan of video games
I can take it the normal guitar for [ __ ]
but I can I know how to play this it's
familiar a kind of interesting thing
you've done is you've set reset the
playing field so even people for big
guitar hero fans are gonna have to have
that like Eureka moment where their hand
does what they want to do all over again
yeah and what's interesting is it's
still familiar right you know we were
playing it earlier and you know my said
these guys have played the game before
it didn't take long for everyone to get
back into it and and it doesn't take
long especially like our expert players
one of the things we find our expert
players who do use the pinking rundown
they kind of have ghost pinky yeah
you're trying to do this for a little
while but it we found it takes like
maybe two songs and the kind of
familiarity of what you're doing kicks
in but then you're into the challenge
and it's like I'm learning something new
at the game is challenging me on a
different level which you know I think
you got to do that with any game people
people don't want the same thing there's
no point in relaunching the series that
you're gonna do the same thing it's like
when Nintendo moved on and you got the
Xbox as the controllers change and they
progress and it just gets better but you
get used to doctor you know minutes yeah
you got it it's like you got to keep up
with the times but then once you're in
there it becomes second nature again
yeah I want to ask you in a second Matt
about the Guitar Hero TV stuff but first
of all since we have this footage up in
front of us here just speak a little bit
about the FMV situation i saw some of
your guys came to our studio a couple of
weeks back and i was playing i think it
was an elbow song and it was like
straight up green screen in the
background yeah and talk about the
process of making that because there's
there's sort of two different levels to
each em FMV are we have four motion
video crowd you out of here
I love the equal to FMV I know even FMV
so is the little kid it's always like
that awesome part of the video game that
look rad and I'm the video kind of
suppose it is a little bit um so
basically you know what we wanted to do
we wanted to we wanted to put you on
stage looking at the crowd and kind of
make you the rock star and and you know
so you can see what it's like you know
being mad and whatnot and is there a
mini game where you have to come and
talk about the game on an e3 as stage
show that's a great idea
stick it in we're gonna do that um so
you know the first thing was let's turn
the camera around let's make you perform
to a crowd you know we had a code word
when we were making it which was stage
fright we wanted to give you stage
fright yeah so then early on with them
so we look you know why don't we do it a
little bit differently than you know
just inside a game engine let's film
real people and then let's try and
figure out a way for them to react
to you so the way we filmed this was we
used a moke on red camera which is like
a giant robot with a camera on the end
of it much like a robot that you would
see building cars on a production line
it's a motion motion control rig isn't
it it's well it's run by motion yes but
it's not like motion control in the
sense that you do motion capture but
yeah motion control it does the same
thing every single time and I you know
you don't have to feed it it doesn't get
tired like all these cameramen that will
do eventually it doesn't do that so it
allowed us basically to film you know
the positive pass and then the negative
pass which means you know if Ben finally
decides to try and screw up for us you
know he'll change like he did there and
the frame it changes is going to be
exactly the same the only difference is
the you know the bands and the crowd's
reaction to you is going to change and
we filmed it
we actually had only about 200 people in
our crowd you know yeah which is with
the one you saw the green screen was
still we hadn't finished that one yet
and we would basically take those people
and then we would move them back just
copy/paste
yeah essentially we copy and paste it
but we did real-life copy and paste so
we'd move them all back do it again do
it again and all of a sudden those two
hundred people they're like four hundred
people there eight hundred people and
we'd move them around and all the tall
ones we'd put in different places that
you couldn't tell and what I like is
that you don't just have massive
amphitheaters you've also got kind of
like shitty dive bars that which
presumably is when you're starting off
in a band you gotta you gotta make your
way up as well yeah well I mean we're in
festivals and stuff like that and then I
mean we used the dive bar in a slightly
different way we want to have it as a
like you know imagine this band goes and
does a gig for it's like hundred biggest
fans yeah like that so we wanted to make
it feel a bit more kind of exclusive so
talk a bit about the sort of the wider
world of guitar obviously you couldn't
do this for every single song that you
were going to release and digital
downloads as a massive part of any of
these types of games they've almost
become like services and so talk a
little bit about that expanded one so
the other part of the game
you know judge TV is what we're talking
about a lot this III and you know I
guess the way easiest way to think about
it is if you go back five years
and you think about how many people were
connected with their consoles it was a
relatively low number sing like less
than 40 percent really
and then like you fast forward to today
and I think it's upwards of 80% across
all consoles we're connected which is a
completely different landscape people
have just gotten used to buying [ __ ] on
the internet well that's the thing like
you know I think about how many of us
have all got Netflix accounts and things
like that and you know we don't own that
content but we just use it when we want
to use it we as consumers we've become
these people that when I want something
I just want it when I want it and I'll
go get it because I am connected so TV
was about building a game that spoke to
that and we're and we were able to give
our fans and friends of the band's
content and music quickly as possible
without having to wait and do another
disc you know we can constantly update
it so TV you know it's it's it's gonna
be several channels there are always
going to be broadcasting when you jump
into it you know you're gonna jump into
whatever channels on and you're gonna
jump into whatever shows on and you can
just play and you just play along and
it'll be multiplayer and you can play
against your friends you'll be match
made against people you can plug another
guitar you can play and then they're
going to be other on-demand shows with
some really cool content and you know I
let Matt talk about that because we're
doing something with avenged that's
really rad and it's gonna be out at
launch and yes we're excited yeah so I
mean at launch we want to be a part of
this game and one thing that was
intriguing to us was to release
something that's never been released
instead of you know a song that you know
kids go online they make their own
versions of these and it's cool to give
them something that they've never had so
we have a bunch of live shows from the
last few years we have playing at
Donington and you know Download Festival
we have Mexico City we have all these
huge shows we recorded we got to be cool
to insert what we do into the game and
do some live tracks that no one has yet
and if you order the game you know
pre-order the game then you get those
tracks so it's the only way to get them
is to get the game early yeah and you
get three Avenged Sevenfold tracks and
we're gonna do a lot of other stuff with
our artwork and with the band in general
but that's how we're gonna start it off
and so that's what we're excited about
is to give people content that they've
never seen yeah obviously that's really
cool for Avenged Sevenfold fans to be
able to get access to not stuff
they withered and mad you've obviously
been have been doing this for a long
time and earlier today I was talking to
Tony Hawk and we were doing this sort of
documentary but the impact that his
franchise has had on video games one of
the things we talked about was how those
games they sold different types of music
to people like I remember listening to
bands and Tony Hawk one two and three I
never heard of and their bands that I
like listen to that like the reason I'm
wearing vans shoes is probably because I
played a bunch of Tony Hawk yeah when
you get involved in these games do you
ever feel like you're apart from you
know getting stuff out there for your
friends you feel like you're scooping up
new fan bases or getting its base you
didn't personally know we did a poll on
our website recently and asked people
where they heard of us and it went
everywhere from Madden 2004 all the way
to Guitar Hero and then a cops in
between so for us you know you look at
the fan base and there's so many people
that were introduced to us yeah from
either beast in the harlot or chapter 4
on Madden 2004 backcountry or Need for
Speed these games and that's what people
they hear the stuff they've never heard
it before they're being exposed to it
the same way radio used to do it yeah it
shows it up the power anymore and so
being a gamer it makes sense for us
because I play so many games that I want
to hear our stuff in it anyways you know
so I'm a fan of it in the first place so
but it's also yeah I mean the audience
is huge and it helps the band's you know
as much or more than it helps the actual
makers of the game so it's it's a good
relationship cool and my pleasure if
that grandma's coming in Jaime pledge
team is you have a fan great job yeah
hey guitar hero there live when will
people be able to play it in what
platforms
well you guys come and play on the show
floor now so if you're around no
internet and you're not anywhere near LA
if you know anywhere near LA then you're
gonna have to wait until October 20th in
the US all right I guess we'll have to
wait and see gentlemen thank you all so
much for coming and enjoy the rest here
III I really appreciate your time delay
they did good a job yeah yeah we got
bunch more stuff back today a new frame
is gonna be on later on showing off his
brand new game on Microsoft but I first
of all we'll be back in just couple of
minutes from mighty number 9 stay tuned